for most of the Year bison bulls
and cows live separate lives but
for a few weeks in late summer
thousands congregate in this
Yellowstone Valley it's the rut
The Mating Season and the
biggest Bulls are busy guarding
their hareem's
a dominant bull might make with
over 50 females
for the calves born this year
now is the time to stretch their
young legs but as the HUD grows
so tensions rise
the rut takes a heavy toll all
on the big balls so arriving now
could give this young Contender
and Edge
but there's life in the old bull
yet
I had to head the Challenger
more than hold his own and he
makes a small mistake
shunted aside his challenge is
brutally ending
the young bull gamble everything
and has paid a heavy price